[Música]
olá meu nome é manuela e hoje eu vim
falar sobre a compra consciente de um
novo celular celular novo necessidade o
impulso
pergunta você realmente precisa de um
celular novo necessidade de compra
aparelho com defeito memória suficiente
sistema desatualizado poucos recursos
bateria viciada impulsos na hora da
compra
o novo modelo de beleza status situação
financeira tamanho desejo do mais novo
utilização adulto normalmente precisa de
um celular mais atualizado com mais
recursos mas isso depende dele criança
o importante é saber que o celular não é
não é feito só para jogos e sim também
para conversar com a família e com os
amigos pode ser um celular mais simples
cuidados na escolha
você já viu uma propaganda de celular
logo depois de comprar e depois percebeu
que ele só que ele fazia as mesmas
coisas do que seu antigo ea beleza dele
ele pode ser mais bonito mas nem sempre
mais útil tempo de uso de cada
equipamento de acordo com uma pesquisa
essa tabela mostra a porcentagem das
pessoas que trocam aparelhos eletrônicos
em menos de três anos
um em cada três celulares são
substituídos por falta de funcionamento
81% dos entrevistados trocam o celular
antes de irem para a assistência técnica
para ver se dá para consertá-los perigos
do skate o meio ambiente
os aparelhos incluindo acessórios e
baterias não podem ser descartados ao
lixo comum pois neles as substâncias
tóxicas que fazem mal ao meio ambiente e
aos seres humanos
essas substâncias podem conter metais
dados como mercúrio chumbo e o cádmio
que causa contaminação do solo dos rios
e do lençol freático
essa imagem mostra uma pilha se
decompondo no solo levando a substância
tóxicas para o lençol freático
muitos agricultores usam essa água que é
para regar as plantas que acabam sendo
contaminadas
essa água também vai para a caixa d'água
da cidade
descarte de pilhas e baterias
vocês sabem onde fazer o descarte
correto nas lojas das operadoras em
alguns supermercados e lixos encontrados
na cor laranja conclusão avalie suas
prioridades necessidades têm se
realmente vai efetuar a compra de um
outro aparelho skate a bateria do seu
celular corretamente
o pt sempre pela pelo consumo consciente
obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]